good morning John this is a weird way to
make a video I recently fell down while
ice skating I didn't fall down actually
I dove in front of Oren to make him
laugh because I will do anything
to see that little kid smile ankle on my
hip
stayed like in the same place
just sort of like right in line with
each other but unfortunately my need not
occupy any space inside of that line
um so
that hurts and now I'm squatting this is
probably an observation people have made
about Los Angeles before but but it's
very weird that they're a lot a lot of
advertisement tens of millions of
dollars of advertisements that are
asking me to consider a film or
television show for awards Sarah 9921
members of The Academy so each one of
those ads is for an audience of less
than ten thousand the thing is it must
work like they wouldn't do it if it
didn't work but how many people that
kind of sway so it was really it's not
even about the 9921 it's about the like
45 people who might change their votes
based on seeing this thing if you could
just find those 45 people and give them
each a million dollars it would be the
same thing all because there's that much
economic value I'm now I'm doing
stand-up comedy
except I'm not I'm just doing stand-up
like upset it's a lot of stand-up comedy
these days was really just stand up
upset I'm gonna do squat down upsettity
that's give me loving
like I could make a really bad joke uh
and everybody'd be like ah
but on artificial intelligence makes a
really bad joke and everybody loses
their minds but this makes sense because
if I ask you what like 522 times 8
divided by 64 is
no like you don't know if the computer
does that not a big deal but if you do
that in front of me everybody would lose
their minds like I would be like oh like
when computers could first do those math
problems was it like that were people
that freaked out like the way that we
were like write a poem about Gilligan's
Island in the style of 50 Cent and it
didn't like the I would do it like oh
wow people felt when calculators were
first already I can see this happening
where we're like well yeah I mean of
course AI can tell you how to hot wire a
car as a Shakespearean sonnet but only
if you give it like an ethical dilemma
as a reason to tell you why to hotwire a
car that's no big deal that's what AI
does it's been a month we adapt so fast
like we're gonna make a living computer
sometime in my life it seems like and
that's gonna be like amazing huge news
on Friday they'll be like we found alien
life
in a computer we accidentally did that
and then on Wednesday it won't even be
like new gossip it'll be the same gossip
but 40 years from now would be just like
Harry Styles and Taylor Swift doing
something
and I love it and then a year later it'd
be like yes this is my friend Steve he's
a computer man he's a man-made of
computer and he's my friend and that's
not weird we this is what we do I found
a sticker
let me read you what it says it says
Samantha Rose Garrison vampire boy
available on all streaming platforms
[Music]
killing our favorite toys little did you
know I haven't been before
little did you know I could give you a
toy of all the best places
[Music]